this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends all of them are tech savvy
one of them is a former competitive
skier who's doubled his strength in a
number of movements using tonal even
though he has a
long athletic background and i'll paint
a picture for you by eliminating
traditional metal weights dumbbells and
barbells tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance which doesn't sound like a
lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still getting a
tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from the four hour body all
sorts of cable exercises that would
usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized
to your body using artificial
intelligence and other
aspects of the engineering and smart
features check your form in real time
just like a personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multi-vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five free travel packs with your first
subscription
purchase many of us are deficient in
vitamin d i found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from sun exposure
so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim
you'll receive up to a year's supply of
vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your subscription
again that's athleticgreens.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
i'm
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job each and every episode to
interview
world-class performers to try to tease
out the habits routines
frameworks favorite books and so on
favorite cereals maybe who knows
that you can apply to your own life and
my guest today
is stephen pressfield i have wanted to
have steven on
this podcast for a very long time you
can find him on twitter at
s press field stephen is a former marine
and graduate of duke university
he became an overnight success as a
writer after 30 years of abject failure
those are his words not mine
so we'll dig into that identifying the
omnipresence if i'm pronouncing that
correctly of resistance
the interior force of self-sabotage he
described in the war of art one of the
best book titles of all time
has saved his own artistic life and
helped many others
struggling to find their creative
calling pressfield's novels of the
ancient world including the non-fiction
the warrior ethos are required reading
at west point annapolis and
in the marine corps he lives in los
angeles his newest book
is a man at arms and epic saga about a
reluctant hero of the roman empire
and the rise of a new faith you can find
him
online stephen with a v
stevenpressfield.com on twitter at
s press field and instagram steven
underscore
pressfield steven welcome to the show
it's great to be here tim i've been
wanting to have a conversation with you
as well
so i'm i'm excited about this too it's
great and we are going to run out of
we are going to run out of time well
before we run out of content i think in
part because i have
all these notes in front of me i have
all these questions and then there
is i'd say at least 51 of you that just
wants to turn this
into a selfish opportunity to
have therapy from you uh so we'll see
what
what blend of all of those elements
i was hoping for the same thing oh
wonderful okay so
from you from me well you know we can we
can turn this into a mutual therapy
session in that case
all right so let's let's go back in time
for those who don't have much context
on your life and perhaps a good entry
point
is a prompt that you provided and that
is
ask me about my house for 15 a month and
the backwoods cat i made friends with
so that's where i'm going to start
please tell me about this house
at 15 a month in the backwoods cat
i went uh when you talked about 30 years
of abject failure
that's that's really true i mean from
the time that i
originally tried to start writing quit a
job
like you did and uh and actually had a
book published was about
you know about 28 years 30 years
something like that
and at one point i was uh
i was driving trucks tractor trailers in
north carolina
and had just come out of living in a
halfway house
that was which was um you know when
people are released from mental
hospitals not me but everybody else was
there
and i finally found i found this house
out in the country for 15 bucks a month
it had no
doors no electricity no
kitchen no toilets nothing i just
basically lived in my van which i parked
on the dirt road there and um
i used to cook there was no way to cook
so i used to have a little fire and make
a little fire out in the back
behind this little house and it was
right up it's you know in north carolina
there's a lot of pine woods
and this was right in the middle of the
pine woods around raleigh
and there used to be this feral cat this
wild cat that lived in the woods
behind me and when i would come out and
cook and i'd be sitting on the back
stoop and the woods started like maybe
only five feet from the house
this cat would sort of materialize he
was an old battle scarred
tom cat you know and he would sit there
across from me while i would make you
know hot dogs or whatever i was doing
and i could never feed him he would
never take anything from me you know i
think it was sort of like
he didn't want to be a pet you know and
he would sit there this is all this is
all true tim i'm not making this up i
believe you he would sit there across
from me
just kind of eyeballing me and there was
no doubt
which one of us was the superior being
you know and no doubt which one of us
had his [ __ ] together
and the other one didn't and and he
would look at me
like he was trying to decide whether or
not to kick my ass or not you know
and but i felt that this cat was a great
omen
i felt that in some way you know why
does a cat materialize like
why does anything happen like that you
know like in the native american
tradition when an animal is kind of a
spirit animal or something right
and uh so i've i took a lot of courage
from that cat appearing i sort of felt
like in some way
my energy had sort of drawn him out of
the woods because he kept coming back
i mean this wasn't a one-time thing and
uh so anyway that's that's uh
that's for a little i don't know if
that's context time
well it's quite a while ago but it was
that was sort of at the heart of my
darkest hours
well it it provides a bunch of
fertile ground for exploration before we
leave the cat though
what meaning did you take from that
what did what effect did that have on
you and then we're going to come back to
the halfway house because you mentioned
everyone else
was there after being released from a
mental hospital or something along those
lines so i want to know how you ended up
there but first what
meaning did you imbue this cat with
after these repeated visits
well i i felt like the cat was a little
bit of a of a role model for me
that it was it was a cat that was
obviously completely self-sufficient
you know lived in the woods didn't
require anybody to feed him
wouldn't let anybody feed him was you
know a totally autonomous individual and
i thought to myself kind of
first of all why did anything come out
of the woods but
if this is what came out of the woods
that it was such a positive kind of
person you know and uh so i thought if
if this cat has come here maybe he's
come here to kind of encourage me and
tell me
that steve you can do that too you know
you can be like me too you can be
autonomous you can be
self-sufficient you can take care of
yourself
you know it makes me think a bit of the
poem wild geese by mary oliver that the
first few lines are i'm not familiar
with that first tell me
i'll tell you the first the first few
lines are you do not have to be good
you do not have to walk on your knees
for 100 miles through the desert
repenting
you only have to let the soft animal of
your body love what it loves that's the
beginning wow and i think about
that quite a bit and contact with
nature and man's tendency and what
i mean by that is mankind's tendency men
and women both
to view themselves as apart from nature
as opposed to a part of
nature and the halfway house
so let's connect the dots from the
beginning to the tomcat at the
end of that first response how did you
end up there
and what was your statement at the time
that you were there
i don't know we're getting into some
deep stuff really early here
i know it's a first date and everything
but i'm going to skip the play a bit if
that's okay
well i was in north carolina at the time
i had married a gal from north carolina
we'd been
you know married for like five or six
years at that time
and we were at the state where we were
desperately trying
to you know we were coming apart at the
seams and we were desperately trying to
hang
on together and we we had come back from
north carolina and we were living with
her mother out in the woods
in a farmhouse that also rented for
about 20 bucks a month
and um i had this a job
delivering industrial food i drove a
little truck
and i would deliver things like
salisbury steaks and uh
frozen crinkle cut french fries
to little restaurants and stuff like
that and uh
without going into a long story i got
fired from that job
and in a state of uh great shame i was
just like
totally ashamed in front of my wife in
front of her mother
and i just sort of i just couldn't stay
there anymore i couldn't
you know i couldn't stay with them so i
kind of i moved into town trying to find
a job
desperately and the only place i could
find was this sort of boarding house
that uh this is in durham north carolina
that was also a halfway house for
you know where the gov the state
government would pay for
people who had been released from mental
institutions
and uh were on their way back into the
real world
and so i found a room in the basement
there
and um that was how i came to that that
halfway house
well and i have a theory about halfway
houses and about the people who are in
there if i do want to hear this tim
i do because i've been in a bunch of
other kind of situations
like that and you think you would think
that people were really struggling
mentally but in fact the people
in this halfway house and we used to
hang out in the kitchen and talk all
night long
were among the smartest people that i
ever met and the funniest and the most
interesting
and what i concluded from hanging out
with them and from others in a similar
situation was that
they weren't crazy at all that they were
actually
the smart people who had sort of seen
through the [ __ ]
and because of that they couldn't
function in the world
they couldn't hold a job you know
because they just couldn't
take the [ __ ] you know and that was
how they kind of wound up
in institutions because the greater
society thought well these people are
absolute rejects they can't fit in
but in fact to my mind they were
actually the people that really saw
through everything
so in a way i felt kind of bad when i
had to leave
this this house because i like the
people so much but also speaks
it seems to not say it isn't
worth it but some of the possible risks
of seeing through the thin veneer
that is what we consider civilization
yeah yeah and just it's a dangerous
thing
just how slippery it can be to
sort of realize how arbitrary so many of
these social constructs are
you you have a
just an incredible resume i mean it it
reads
like i don't want to say hero's journey
because we'll probably come to that and
clarify that a bit later but
you have an eclectic to put it mildly a
collection
of professions you have tractor trailer
driver
cab driver school teacher you picked
fruit as a migrant laborer
it and the list goes on of all of those
does one stand out as having been
especially
formative for who you then later became
as a writer as a creative driving
tractor trailers was
probably the most formative thing for me
in that sense in the sense that
once you're out on the road delivering a
load
you're completely on your own and if
anything goes wrong i mean obviously you
can call for help if you're really
desperate
but pretty much you've got to get it
together
one way or another and other people are
depending on you whatever that load is
you've got to deliver it the shipper
wants it the people it's being shipped
to one and there's really sort of no
mercy you know you're you have to be a
professional you have to do it and
at the time that i was doing this job
i was really dealing with my own
tendency to sabotage myself i mean i was
like a self-destruction machine
you know where i would just screw up
constantly and i had to be
constantly you know monitoring myself
that i wouldn't act out in some crazy
way
and destroy everything that i was you
know trying to do which was just to
survive
so first of all the help from the people
that i worked with
from the other drivers from the
dispatcher who was kind of a mentor to
me a guy named hugh reeves who
really saved my life in a lot of ways
and also just the
the need to deliver to really actually
deliver the goods
and the self-imposed pressure of that
that really helped me
and you know there were a bunch of
instances when i found myself
really up against it and having to get
it together completely on my own
and when i thought i never could and
each time that i was able to do that it
reinforced that and kind of like the cat
that came out of the woods
i sort of felt like i was being a little
bit of my own role model and that there
was hope that i
that i could get it together one way or
another at that time
in that period you mentioned the
self-sabotage
and i'll give you two questions and you
can take a stab at either or both
what was the particular form or most
common form of self-sabotage if you
could
give an example or just describe that
because there are so many different
types and then also
hugh reeves as a mentor what type of
mentor was he what did you
glean or learn from him i'll give you a
specific when i was
driving the little trucks and delivering
institutional food to these little
restaurants like title houses and stuff
like that
the way i got fired was it was uh early
in the morning i just finished
delivering to uh
to a restaurant i hadn't had breakfast
and i was coming back out through the
through the sort of the warehouse
section at the back of the restaurant
and they had a whole bunch of rows of
little cans of
fruit juice you know pineapple juice and
stuff like that and so i just reached
out and i grabbed one for myself
and the boss caught me and you know
i'm putting them on but i'm fired and i
really feel like
me doing that was an act of
self-destruction
that i had and i'm i absolutely am
certain of it you know
i just sort of knew you know why do you
do something like that
so that was kind of the sort of thing
that i would do kind of over and over
and um you know and driving trucks
i could tell a bunch of stories but one
of them was where
i dropped the trailer one time
delivering it meaning
i pulled the tractor out from under the
trailer
in this uh warehouse parking lot right
in front of about 500 people
and just dropped this entire trailer
nose down
onto the thing and was just a complete
fiasco
so that was the kind of thing that i
would do or i would just be careless
you know you you know you need to like
if you're an airline pilot you and
you're doing your your checklist you
know you have to
before you take off you got to hit check
the flaps and the engine and blah blah
blah whatever it is
i would there was something in me that
would make me
forget to check the one most important
thing that i had to do and as soon as
it went wrong i knew it you know it
wasn't like oh what a surprise it was
like oh
[ __ ] i've done it again you know and
getting back to your hugh reeves who was
a dispatcher who was my mentor
in this thing he after i got fired i'm
really
i don't know i guess this is interesting
i don't know i find it interesting
after i got fired from stealing that can
of pineapple juice
i was in a state of utter shame i didn't
even tell my wife or
her mother i just and i i had already
applied
for i had gone to a truck driving school
and i had applied to like 50 different
companies throughout north carolina
and couldn't get on anywhere and i was
just
leaving town in my 65 chevy van
heading for the oil fields in louisiana
where i'd worked once before
and where i knew i could at least get a
job all you needed was a pulse
and then take you on and so on my way
out of town
in uh like uh the dead of winter worst
possible rainy
north carolina st i stopped at this one
trucking company that i had already
flied to a couple times and they
rejected me
and hugh reeves was the dispatcher and
uh
he was a former marine and he knew that
i had been marine
and i just stopped just for the hell of
it i thought this is work you know
things that have and he hired me
so that kind of saved my life right
there but throughout the whole
uh my struggles to learn the business
and stuff like that there was i'll tell
you there was one
one moment where he kind of sat me down
and
i had kept screwing up like i said and
he sat me down alone in his office and
he said uh you know son and i was like i
don't know what 25 years younger than
him
he said um i don't know what's going on
in your head son
i don't know what journey you're playing
out here i don't know what your issues
are
i don't know what you're trying to solve
in your own inner mind
but this company is a business
we're in business to make money you are
a driver
you represent this company when i give
you a load to take somewhere
you better [ __ ] deliver that load you
know
and and so that was a great thing for me
you know to you know it was like a slap
in the face
because i in my mind i definitely was
kind of on this odyssey i was living on
an inner
world i don't know what it was and he
was absolutely right this is a business
you know this is for real i have a real
job people are depending on me i have to
i have to
and that really helped me to sort of
think of myself as much as i could as a
professional
and not somebody on some crazy adventure
i can definitely see how that ties into
a lot that came later
that's a great story yeah that's a great
story let's flash forward we're going to
bounce around quite a bit
and in doing so i want to
maybe first bring up just a common
belief or sentiment that i hear a lot
which is like you're going to do your
best work
in your 20s it's like a professional
sport you do a b and c and you've kind
of reached escape velocity or not
by the time you're 30 35 whatever the
number might be but it tends to be
around there
your first novel you mentioned in some
comments a few minutes ago and i
mentioned it the bio 30 years of abject
failure
okay so your first novel published
after around 30 years of effort the
legend of bagger advance
how old were you when that was published
i think i was 53 all right maybe 54.
okay so now a lot happened up to that
point obviously in your life
you had a lot of experiences where i
want to go next
is is to ask
how you developed your facility with
words
because you are a very good writer the
the jobs we've mentioned so far seem to
have nothing to do
with with wordsmithing you have
you have an incredible vocabulary how
did this
happen i'll accept and thank you for
saying that to him i said that at face
value
but please do through the whole time
that um
you know i wasn't only doing blue collar
jobs i
i worked in advertising like in new york
three or four times and i also had about
a ten-year career
as as a screenwriter in
los angeles where i am now and um
so through that time you're uh
trying to learn what what a writer is
and what being or what writing is and
also of course i was
i was writing novels through that time
you know i wrote three of them that
never got published
so and each one took about two years
full time
what drove you to do that if i could
just pause there for a second
sure most people don't write periods so
what was driving you
or compelling you or inspiring you to do
that you know i don't know it's why does
anybody write or why does anybody paint
or anything
i um it sort of originally started for
me i knew
it was not a dream i had as a kid you
know i didn't
you know like jack carr the thriller
writer and former navy seal he
always wanted to be a thriller writer
from the time he was like six years old
but not not me it never occurred to me
my first job was in advertising in new
york and i had a boss named ed hannibal
who wrote a novel uh quit wrote her
novel and it was a huge success
overnight
and i sort of thought well [ __ ] why
don't i do that too
it seems like it seems like an easy gig
let's try it nothing too
right i mean he's in that office i'm in
this office why can't i do it
so that sort of at least started this
kind of dream for me
you know and then once i had failed at
it really badly i thought
i was even more motivated to do it right
i've gotta like somehow i've gotta
you know write my way out of this thing
one way or another
so that was how it initially started tim
in terms of
just the intention to do it to finally
make it work i want to allow people to
peek behind the scenes here for a second
just to see
sort of how the sausage is made with
this podcast
and i'm looking in front of me at a
whole
raft of papers but one of them
contains prompts and exploratory bullets
and i always
ask guests if they would like to provide
any prompts
that might lead to interesting or fun
stories
fertile ground as i like to say for
exploration
and you learn a lot about guests
looking at the bullets they provide or
the lack of bullets they provide
and your bullets are fantastic and i i
this this
this will be tied into what we're
talking about in just a second but
so for instance right ask me about the
house for 15 a month in the backwood
cat i made friends with another one
which we're not going to get into right
now but we'll probably come back to we
might come back to us ask me about the
time when i was driving trucks when they
told me quote whatever you do
don't in all caps go past that last
right turn
end quote now to me then speaking of
course i did go past that last thing
of course now as someone who has read i
want to say it was john caples and all
these books
on copywriting i can
see very clearly and i say this as a
compliment
the influence of your time
as a copywriter working at agencies it's
it's so obvious to me because it's you
can't not ask i mean it is
is very well crafted in that sense could
you speak
to your learnings
in the world of advertising what did you
gain from
working as a copywriter whether at i
think benton and
bowles is that one of the things yeah
that was one of the places yeah yeah
and i do think in many ways i learned a
tremendous amount in advertising i mean
i hate advertising i hate it when it's
on
the screen i hate watching tv
commercials i hate the whole concept of
it
but i met a lot of great people there
and i learned a lot and one of the
things you know one of the books that
i've written about writing as you know
is called nobody wants to read your [ __ ]
yeah please for those people who don't
know it this is just a
spectacular piece if you could
describe it yeah and the the sort of the
this is to me like
the number one lesson that any writer or
artist
should know before they know anything
else and you learn this in advertising
because as you're as you're trying to
write an ad or a tb commercial one thing
you have to always keep in mind
is that nobody wants to see it in fact
they hate it sight unseen they hate it
if it's a tv commercial they've got
their remote in their hand and i'm going
to click right through it as fast as
they can
you know or if it's an ad that's in a
newspaper or magazine
they're going to turn the page as fast
as they can because they hate it they
don't want you to
sell them preparation h or anything like
that right
so the lesson for that as a writer
knowing that you're facing that was so
much resistance from the
from the reader is that whatever you're
going to put on that page or on the tv
screen
it's got to be so good and so compelling
and so interesting
that people will have no choice but to
watch it and so it makes you work
really really hard and also makes you
really
project yourself into the mind of the of
the viewer or the reader
in an empathetic way in a really good
way and try to say what would be
interesting to them what would catch
their interest and what would
hold their interests and you realize too
that
writing isn't or and reading is a
transaction
that the reader or the viewer is giving
you a very valuable commodity which is
their
time and their attention and you've got
to give them something
you can't just put some crap out there
and expect that they're obligated to
read it or watch it because they won't
watch it you know so
that was that was a great lesson for me
that applied in
writing novels or movies or anything at
all that you're going to do
a restaurant if you're going to open a
restaurant you know nobody wants to come
in there and
and buy your greasy cheeseburgers you
know you've got to
come up with something that makes them
say i've got to go in there you know
and that's where the work comes in and
that's where the creativity comes in
and another sidebar to that tim of what
you learn in advertising
is a 30-second commercial
cannot have more than 60 words in it
two words per second because an
announcer or people speaking actors
speaking can't deliver it it becomes so
fast that you can't hear
so there's pressure on you every time
you write a piece
of copy like i would bring a piece of
copy into my boss whoever he was or she
was
and they would say get out of here this
is way too long go back to your cubicle
and cut it down and i'd spend like hours
cutting it down
and bring it back and then they'd say
cut it down again
and so that was a wonderful skill to
learn
to find that you can say maybe in 25
words
what you had said in 250 words before
so you're right tim you're right on
target that there was a lot of lessons
that came out of
that experience of writing ads i
mentioned
in passing and i'm by no means an expert
here but mentioned in passing
hero's journey in in reference to your
your life in a sense
but my understanding is that you
consider
the hero's journey as perhaps we know it
in the joseph campbell sense
different from the artist's journey
could you please
elaborate on that ah i definitely feel
this time that you and i are talking
about now when i was driving trucks and
doing things like that
and being kind of lost and in the
wilderness as
my quote-unquote hero's journey i mean i
think we all
have many heroes journeys but we
probably have
one sort of overarching one and to me
the hero's journey of our lives
is takes us from believing that we
are what our parents told us we are or
what society told us we are
or what we imbibed from the culture
shedding that and finally finding out
who we
really are and that's sort of the moment
the hero's journey always ends in joseph
campbell terms
with the hero coming home right like
odysseus coming back to ithaca
and at that point the
we've hopefully we've kind of found who
we are and what our calling is
and for me you know that was it was a
long it was a long journey but at that
point
a new stage of our life takes over like
i'll say for me
it was when i finally got a novel
published the legend of bagger vance
so that took me like 28 years of
quote-unquote hero's journey
and in my view this is me thinking about
this later i had no concept at the time
at that point at that point i said to
myself i'm a writer i'm a real writer i
can do it i've
paid my dues and then the next question
became okay now what am i going to write
about
what is my gift if i'm here to bring
kind of a gift to the people as the
hero's journey
template says my question to myself is
what is that gift so for the rest of my
life i feel at that point i got on my
artist journey
and now i'm a writer i'm going to write
one thing i'm going to write another i'm
going to write another and the question
i'm asking myself
is what is what is book one what is book
two what is book three
what is my gift what am i here to give
and you know um i'll i'll blather on for
a bit here tim if you don't lose i love
i love your blathering um if you've ever
heard of richard rohr
who wrote uh falling upward i think it
is he's a he's a franciscan monk
and a very deep thinker and he kind of
divides life
into two halves first half and second
half and the first half of your life he
says
is when you're sort of finding your
identity
and kind of establishing your presence
on the planet you know like
maybe you're a mom and you say oh okay
i'm a mom you know
i'm that or i'm a lawyer i bought a
house
i have a wife i have children you're
sort of in his
words richard rohr's words r-o-h-r
if you want to look it up i highly
recommend anything by him you're
creating the vessel
that is your life and then in the second
half of your life
you're filling that vessel so you sort
of ask yourself okay
now i can do it i've got a house i've
whatever
um i have a profession what am i gonna
do with this
am i just gonna be another crappy person
that's
that's you know uh continuing the the
societal
garbage that we have or am i going to
try to find
my gift that's unique to me and bring it
forth to the world and try to help
in one way or another so that to me is
there's the hero's journey comes first
and when the hero's journey is over our
artist journey begins
and i would define art as the broadest
possible terms
anything that is a gift to the to the
wider
world
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin sales navigator linkedin sales
navigator is the best version of
linkedin for sales
professionals get ready to exceed your
2021 sales goal
with the help of linkedin sales
navigator that's what it's built for the
best
sales people know that closing deals is
about understanding your customers needs
and building relationships it's time to
reimagine in-person selling and cold
calling
for the digital world nowhere is this
more true in post-covet
so tap into the power of linkedin's 700
million plus
member network linkedin sales navigator
gives you 20 monthly in-mail messages
lead recommendations unlimited searches
actionable insights and news
and access to free courses on linkedin
learning target the right prospects and
decision makers
unlocking 15 more pipeline from sourced
opportunities
a 17 lift when saving leads on sales
navigator
and 42 percent larger deal sizes as the
world adapts to new working habits
sellers must also shift tactics to stay
ahead linkedin sales navigator is here
to help
sales professionals do exactly that so
start your 60 day free trial that's a
two month free trial
of linkedin sales navigator today by
going to linkedin.com
navigator that's linkedin.com
navigator n-a-v-i-g-a-t-o-r
to start your 60 day free trial of
linkedin sales navigator
one more time linkedin.com navigator
part of the hero's journey as i
understand it please correct me if i'm
getting this wrong is what is sometimes
referred to as refusal of the call
right like when luke skywalker is just
bitching and whining and doesn't want to
go see yoda etc
like you know he's just being a pain in
the ass to obi-wan kenobi you everyone
should re-watch star wars if you don't
remember this part
or this section was there
that element in your
hero's journey getting to the point of
having created the vessel was there
a refusal of the call did that did that
play any role
oh absolutely and i think it does in
everybody's
life you know the re in the hero's
journey as joseph campbell lays it out
there's a bunch of stages and
the hero's journey usually it starts in
what joseph campbell would call the
ordinary world
and it's just you know you're living
your regular life but
something is wrong like in the case of
luke skywalker
he's on uh uncle owen and aunt varu's
evaporator farm on
tatooine i guess is the planet right you
got it and he's just
right and and this is his ordinary life
right
he's stuck he's nowhere in fact i think
there's a
somebody asked him at some point where
are you and he says
if there's a spot that's the farthest
point away from the bright center of the
universe
that's where i am right and that's so
that's kind of the ordinary and then
what the next day this is very early in
the hero's journey
and then the next stage is the call and
it's something
happens that tends to pull you out of
this ordinary world like in
the wizard of oz it's dorothy gets swept
up in the tornado
in star wars it's that luke skywalker
finds r2d2
and he you know unplugs the little
hologram that says
princess leia help me obi-wan kenobi
you're my only hope right
so that's the call right suddenly he
realized uh oh
i've got to do something here and then
what follows immediately after that
in joseph campbell paradigm is the
refusal of the call
for luke he goes no i can't leave i've
got responsibilities for aunt varu and
uncle
and blah blah blah and that seems to be
across the board if you if you remember
the first
rocky the movie when rocky when apollo
creed or the promoter
calls rocky into his office and says i'm
going to give you a shot to fight the
champ
and rocky's first reaction is no i can't
do it
you're crazy this is a joke i can't do
it
or if we want to go back to another one
when odysseus is being summoned
to go fight in the trojan war his first
reaction is no no no i don't want to do
it and
if you remember the myth he pretends to
be crazy
and he goes out and he's sowing his
fields with salt
and the messenger who is sent to summon
him
takes his baby the young telemachus
odysseus baby
and puts him in a furrow in the path of
the
of the plow and when odysseus comes to
the baby
he veers around it right he's not going
to run over his baby
and the messenger says ah you're faking
you're really not crazy
get on the boat we're going to the
trojan war so
that's the refusal of of the call and
for me
it was the first novel that i tried to
write
which i had no business doing i got like
two minutes from the end and i just blew
it up
and blew my my whole life up it was that
was my refusal i refused
to go into this the unknown world
how did you blow it up do you mean that
you just stopped you thinking well i'm
not going to tell you exactly
details but i did something that made my
wife hate me and
kicked me out i got it okay so that's
why i acted out what as they would say
in psychological terms in other words
another form of self-destruction you
know that
that was that was my those are my demons
forever
they may be your demons forever but
perhaps you're getting
or have become better at dancing with
them instead of struggling
against them it seems like at least
referring to your mentors and
lessons learned that in some respect
and please correct me disabuse me of
this so it's not true
that you've been able to at least like
strike a deal with these demons because
yes you went from being unable
to finish a novel to producing
many works what is that deal or
how how has that come to be the case
well let me just
talk about a novel for a second please
after the first one that i wrote
that i couldn't finish and i went on
these various you know spiraling down
the rattle type of things
i i finally got it together i saved some
money i saved twenty seven hundred
dollars working in advertising in new
york
and i moved out to a little town in
northern california
and determined to write a novel and
finish it and i rented this little house
and i was just by myself and through
that whole time again i was
aware every second of my tendency to
sabotage myself
so i just said to myself i'm gonna
finish this son of a [ __ ] or i'm gonna
kill myself
and when i finally did and i write about
this in the war of art
when i finally did finish it and i've
typed those words
the end i felt like my dna
changed you know and i will say
that as an encouragement to anybody
that's listening that's struggling with
the same stuff
once i was able to finish that thing
that novel
i've never had any trouble finishing
anything ever again that's interesting
but it was
just sheer willpower driven on by
shame you know that i just couldn't you
know
i think shame is a great thing yeah but
i think but i just couldn't
stand myself if i failed yet again so i
just had to keep going keep going keep
going
it seems like it's possible and
i'm speculating here but the when you
finish that
novel and you had the end right because
confidence is just not something you can
fake right and
in the respect that you you yeah your
true self knows whether
you've earned your hearts unearned when
you typed the
end the story of i
always self-sabotage now had a
counter-example that
that statement was no longer ah
i never thought about it that way tim
but i think you're absolutely right yeah
a counter example
yeah with the legend of bhagavan so
finishing a novel is one thing getting a
novel published
is quite another endeavor in many
respects so
30-year overnight success
what happened did you end up like
drawing straws and you became the bridge
partner of a book agent like what what
actually happened
that allowed this this publication
publishing your first book well like
like i said
i wound up writing three novels that
never got published
right and uh when i finished the third
one
that was sort of like another kind of an
all is lost moment a suicide moment for
me because
i couldn't get any even my friends
wouldn't read it and i knew that i just
didn't have
the wherewithal to do this again you
know to save up money to work for two
years that's
it i just didn't have the wherewithal
and so i decided
uh or sort of came to me as a flash that
i would go to hollywood
i thought let me write a screenplay let
me write let me try hollywood
if i failed as a novelist let me go fail
as a screenwriter
so i did go out to los angeles and after
about
you know four or five years i got my a i
did have an agent i kept writing
screenplays that
also didn't sell and finally i got kind
of teamed up with
an established writer a guy named ron
shusett who did the first
alien among other things and it was like
a really
a real brand name and a real uh you know
a guy that really could get work
how did you get teamed up with them i'm
sorry to keep interrupting but like like
alien turned into an iconic
film i mean created a great franchise
great
how did you get teamed up with him i had
an agent
a wonderful agent named mike warner who
tragically died at a young age
but uh and you know he had other clients
and ron was one of his other clients
and ron usually worked with a partner
and at that time
because he was more ron was more of a
producer writer than a writer writer
what is a producer writer a writer
writer
is the guy that actually sits down at
the page at the typewriter
and actually writes the scenes and so on
and so forth
a producer writer is somebody who is
great at coming up with
the ideas the big ideas and also sort of
shepherding a story through uh from
start to finish
and also as a producer in the sense of
being able to
get financing and right and take the
meetings and make a deal
so whereas ron was not the kind of
writer that could actually sit down and
write the screenplay
you know but he could say you know i
would sit there and come up with like 30
ideas what if we do this what if we do
that what do we get
and he would say 29 of them suck do this
one
he's the guy who would say it's jaws in
space
act one two three here's the deck
he could line up all of the ducks in a
row to get the financing
yeah for instance the great scene in
alien where the thing
bursts out of john hurt's chest right
you know that's i mean that is ron's
scream
you know that was his idea which is
burned into every anyone's mind who has
ever seen one of the aliens movies
so you can't say just because maybe he
didn't actually physically write it at
the typewriter
that was his you know so so it's a very
creative thing to be a producer
so he usually works with a partner he's
more of a producer writer instead of the
writer writer you have the same agent
please continue so the agent said mike
said to us so let me team you guys up
and you'll be
you'll be a team so that from my point
of view i now became like an apprentice
i was like the junior partner of this
team and
when we'd go to meetings in hollywood
nobody wanted
me they wanted ron he was the brand and
i was just you know
you know i was the guy that actually sat
at the keyboard so in any event
for maybe 10 years or so i did have a
career as a screenwriter
so that was gaining credibility for me
and also
i was learning what a story is you know
by by
you know the process that you go through
and then at one point
i just had this idea for the legend of
bagger vance and i had it as a book
not as a movie and so when i told that
to my
agent then at the time he basically
fired me
you know he basically said
unscientifically
broken my story isn't i fired him but
his story is that he fired me
but basically he uh he was absolutely
right because what he said to me was
i've spent the last five years trying to
get your career going
and we're now just about to get going
and you're telling me you're gonna write
some stupid golf
novel that nobody's gonna buy and
nobody's gonna read
it's gonna take you a year to write it
and by that time everybody will
forgotten who you are here in the
business in hollywood
and i'm back to square one and i've
spent a lot of time working with you so
get out of here so but in any event
that was how an actual novel that i
wrote actually got published
so it was it was sort of a smooth
transition and when you know the actual
the actual passage there didn't just
come out of nowhere so if you broke up
with this agent or he broke up with you
you go off to write this thing the agent
has these
these doubts and believes that you're
going to
sort of sink into oblivion
and become irrelevant right you're just
going to be
completely forgotten you march off
to pursue this this dream
and this project from there not to be a
dead horse about this but like how does
it then
find a home with a publisher you know it
was like
i joked that i was an overnight success
after 30 years
and i think sometimes uh your bad luck
builds up to such an extent that it
turns into good luck right the law of
averages
starts to work for you right and what
happened was
to try to get you have to get a literary
agent right which i didn't have i had a
hollywood agent
so i went to my lawyer i had an
entertainment lawyer named larry rose
and he sent me to uh an agent named jody
hatches in new york who worked for
sterling lord who's a a big literary
agent
who is still my agent and just turned
100 years old
wow by the way and so almost
overnight that manuscript just found a
buyer boom boom boom
found a buyer found a movie buyer found
everything right away
so it was i think it was just the law of
averages finally evened out a little bit
that's just incredible what a story so
i'd like to
ask you about momentum in your life
and i'm asking this is this is where i
might
segue at least indirectly into some
therapy for myself
so i am i am looking
at an interview you've done and
it's discussing the little successes
approach and i'm just going to read a
first paragraph then you can tell me if
things have changed
but the first paragraph and this is your
response to a question i think this is
on writingroutines.com
i'm at the gym at 5 30 every morning but
it takes me until around 11
30 to actually sit down and start work i
used to be able to put in four hours but
these days two and a half is my outer
limit i close the office then i never
work later or at night
and then you talk about your friend
randy could you speak to
the little successes approach and what
this what this schedule represents
randy is randall wallace who wrote
braveheart and has directed a bunch of
movies as well
and he's a good friend of mine out here
and he has a theory
that he calls little successes and he
means that from
the moment he gets out of bed and i
believe this too exactly
he's looking to build up he's looking
ahead to the moment when he
actually sits down and has to write
whatever time that may be for him nine
o'clock ten o'clock whatever
and he's trying to produce a series of
little successes
between now and then to generate
momentum and he counts like brushing his
teeth as a little success
and i do too and one of the one of the
reasons i like to go to the gym
early or do something physical early is
because i'm trying to build up little
successes
so that by the time i get to sit down at
the at the page
i feel like i've got some momentum going
you know i've done i've done this i've
done that i've taken out the garbage you
know i've
you know fed the birds and i've got a
little momentum going because i
and i think it's very important i mean
even if you think about
let's say a basketball player think
about kobe bryant or michael jordan or
anybody steph curry or whatever going to
the
game tonight you know they're at the at
the stadium like three and a half hours
early and even before then they've been
at the gym
or they've been getting a massage or
they've now mentally they're preparing
themselves
and they go through you know they do
their if you watch steph curry do his
routine
it you know it's like i don't know what
it's amazing what he does
you know big rubber bands between his
knees and stretch
strength in his knees and then he does
you know 100
shots from you know beyond the arc and
he's trying to build up
little successes so that when the game
starts
he's in the flow immediately and he's at
the highest possible level
that's the theory anyway what is your
preferred
exercise routine do you have any
favorite exercises or workouts
i'm in the now on the covet thing where
i'm doing it out on my deck
but for up until the covid thing i
trained with a wonderful trainer named
tr goodman
at a place called pro camp gold's gym in
venice
and he has a you know a whole thing that
he does with
us who train with him you should train
in a group of two or three guys
and uh it's basically just just really
straight
basic weight training you know squats
and curls and stuff like that you know
legs on one day you know this just very
basic stuff
that's a very iconic location as far as
gyms go
yeah yeah it's now it's all in a tent in
the parking lot
right so it's changed a bit during
pandemic times
so the little successes approach makes
sense to me and really
appeals to me and there's there's so
much variation
of course when you talk to writers about
process right so
i recently interviewed joyce carol oates
and i've when i was an undergrad
took a just a wonderful seminar with
john mcphee and both of them
seem to basically sit down chain
themselves to a desk and write for eight
hours and their feeling is
you can't wait for mood you can't wait
for the muse to strike you really just
need
to start writing and that will produce
the conditions for writing
i have sometimes had the experience of
that working
but perhaps it's just a weakness of
character i often
break i also just break i'm just like
god this is
[ __ ] terrible and i stopped and
then you have maybe a contrast and i'm
not saying this is all or nothing
one approach to the other but folks like
bj novak who people might
recognize who spends quite a lot of time
getting himself
into a good mood so he might take a few
hours to get himself into the proper
mood to write
and he's prolific and very successful
and then there's this little successes
approach
i suppose the question piggyback off of
this
is how should someone think about
developing a routine for their own
writing process or creative process
let's stick with writing just because
it's
it's what we're talking about even
though i think the discussion extends to
many other areas
how should somebody think about figuring
it out because i
even for me personally
i have well we'll talk about this
afterwards but i've been
having quite a lot of challenges writing
in the past few years and so i've tried
to reach into the grab bag of different
routines and i found it challenging
because so many of them are
diametrically opposed or seem to be
yeah how would you talk someone through
finding something that works for them or
making sense of conflicting advice
the one thing i would say is that it
seems to me that every writer or artist
has a unique way of doing it and i don't
think there's any kind of
one-size-fits-all type of thing
like there was an article in the la
times a few years ago where they
interviewed screenwriters
and they were asking what was their
routine they interviewed like five
writers
and three of them wrote in their cars
and this is true and one of them
wrote in the car when it was moving
now i don't know how they did this
but it just goes to show you that
whatever works works
you know uh like joyce carol oates or
john mcphee doing eight hours
that is beyond my comprehension it's
just i mean that's yeah that's like alex
honold and free solo but for the writing
world i
yeah i can't can't process that but i
i do agree with them that you know
there's a
famous quote uh that i quoted in um
in the war of art and now i'm i'm
blanking on who
who was a famous writer who they asked
him uh
do you write on a schedule or only when
inspiration strikes you oh somerset mom
and he said i write only when
inspiration strikes me
he says fortunately it strikes me every
morning at 9 30
so he was a believer in routine
right and another person there's a
wonderful book
by twyla tharp i'm sure you're aware of
this tim called the creative habit
and she kind of describes her habits and
she's kind of like me she goes to the
gym at the crack of dawn
every day she she catches a cab at
exactly the same time goes the exact
same place
and she's trying to build up those
little successes
for when she gets to the studio and
actually has to work
but to go a little deeper than that you
know in
in my book the war of art i talk about
the concept of resistance with a capital
r
which is again that force of
self-sabotage is a big theme in my life
that will try to stop you as a writer
or an artist or anybody from achieving
your best work from
following your calling will try to
distract you undermine your
self-confidence make you procrastinate
make you quit make you give into fear or
on the other hand make you
such a perfectionist that you spend all
day on one paragraph and
you accomplish nothing and the whole
thing of little success is the concept
of little successes
or of a routine is to help you overcome
that resistance
to help anybody over that's the wall
that you know you're going to hit
you know right and so you're mentally
preparing yourself
for that moment when you sit down and
that negative force hits you
that you you've got enough momentum and
enough self-confidence
or your friend who gets himself in a
good mood you're in enough of a good
place you got enough good karma and good
juju going for you
that you could get through that wall of
resistance and then
just get into a rhythm and get into the
flow and then just keep it going
that's the whole sort of concept behind
little successes or a routine or habits
and i'm a big believer in habits me too
when i have been
i suppose what we might call successful
in writing
just getting anything consistently on
pages
it's been with some form of scaffolding
in the form of routine and one that
actually worked for me i hadn't thought
about this
to finish at least one book maybe two
was copying what i believe it was uh
maya angelou maybe who
would rent a hotel room to work out
to put herself in a different
environment that was dedicated to
writing
and when i was living in san francisco i
remember
hotel vitali was this this hotel right
on the embarcadero
and i would i would rent a room
when i got really stuck to put myself
in a different environment and for
whatever reason i mean let's
i'm sure it's placebo effect because how
could it not be right it's got to be
harnessing the mind and kind of pulling
a aikido move on your own psyche
that really really helped you've
mentioned a number of books
so the war of art i think everyone
should read certainly
then twyla tharp's creative habit i've
also
read you mentioned stephen king's on
writing ernest hemingway on writing
yeah larry phillips and henry miller on
writing henry miller's just incredible
one that i'm not familiar with i would
love to hear you just expand on for a
second
and the line here that i'm reading is
for integrating the editor's mindset
into the writing process the best book
is the story grid
by sean coyne i think it is c-o-y-n-e
what does that mean the editor's mindset
into the writing process
before i say to that i want to say that
your idea of checking into a hotel room
i think is a great idea and it is and
that's something that
might be unique to you tim that might be
a trick that works for you
it's safer than driving a car in writing
because yeah
but sir it is kind of an aikido it's a
way of tricking yourself to
somehow you know oh i can i can't work
there but i can work here
if it works it works you know right
right totally
but the story grid sean coyne is
actually was my first editor he was the
editor who bought gates of fire
oh no kidding and we are amazing we're
best we're really good friends
and we're partners in a little
publishing company that we have
called black irish books so i know
sean very well and sean is he's a
harvard guy
and um he's uh has evolved this concept
of
editing that he calls the story grid
and it's incred it's incredibly deep if
you and i were looking at this
it would it was like it's like einstein
you know i can't even gra
begin to grasp what it is but he really
has a whole concept from
a to z of what a story is what a scene
is and so on and so forth
that he calls a story grid and he
actually i highly recommend
his website www.storygrid.com
if you want to be an editor if you want
to be a writer he teaches this whole
concept and it's great but getting back
to
integrating the editor's mindset to the
writer's mindset
a lot of times i found me as a writer
i will just sort of spew stuff out in a
novel
let's say i'll just be consumed with a
story and i'll just take it from a to z
without even thinking about it
and then i have to bring it to sean and
he
kind of tells me what the story is about
which i never had any clue
what the theme is and also will help to
shape it into an actual story that
really works
and a lot of the editor's mindset has to
do with the hero's journey
and that whole concept of act one act
two act three
refusal of the call that we were talking
about earlier
and sean has a another company of his
own that he calls
genre management and he's a big believer
in genre
in the sense that like a thriller has
certain
obligatory scenes and conventions and a
love story has certain obligatory scenes
and conventions
a western has certain and and you have
to know them
and that's what an editor does you know
for instance if
if you're going to have a love story
there always has to be a rival
that's a big thing think of any story
love story in the world
and there's also almost always has to be
the lovers part in the middle or towards
the end and then they come
back together at the end or they fail to
come back together at the end
and that's kind of what an editor brings
to
uh to a writer's huge pile of papers
that you bring and
dump on the editor's desk is he or she
is kind of aware of the various
structures that actually
work and the the kind of the principles
of storytelling
and when you violated them an editor can
bring you back from that you know or
when you have
left certain things out that need to be
in there
an editor will say you know you need to
do this
and so if you can educate yourself as a
writer in that editor's way of thinking
you can sort of become your own editor
in a sense and it really helps you
i mean i do maybe 15 drafts of a book
and you know seventh eighth ninth i'm
really thinking like an editor i'm
looking at this and saying
what's missing what have i done wrong
what uh you know
what what conventions have i violated
and if i
if i have violated them do i have a good
reason for it
so i'm not sure that's an answer to him
but that's that is the answer
i highly recommend anything to do with
sean coyne and story grid
i'm going to ask you about a man at arms
first i want to take
this opportunity to paint a picture
of the last week in my life if i may be
self-indulgent for a second please do we
just do so i
i have this newsletter called five
bullet friday it's five short bullets of
things that i found interesting or
helpful or novel throughout each week
and i had the experience a subscriber by
the way
oh wonderful i appreciate that so i know
all about it i love doing it
and it serves as a diary of sorts for me
and
i had the experience in the last week of
one of those bullets
expanding dramatically and ultimately
becoming
close to a 10-page blog post which if
people want to check out it's related to
conservation and ethical choices in the
world of psychedelic compounds
they can find it at tim.blog but the
point that i want to make
or the contrast maybe is i wrote this
piece i was very happy to have
finally written this piece even though
i'm catching heat from certain
factions within the psychedelic
communities for it
because it's been a very long time since
i've written a blog post a long form
blog post
and that having been said i was
i was interviewed yesterday by
a friend of mine harley of shopify
fame and
he read a passage from the four hour
work week in the course of that
interview because he's he's read the
book
he's very kind he wanted to use it as a
as a launching pad for
discussion and he read a few paragraphs
for the four hour work week and
and here's what you can probably guess
here's what i thought to myself
god damn i have done nothing
but become worse at writing since i was
29.
what in you know for [ __ ] sake what am
i doing with my life
and i and i became
hyper self critical i was like man like
look at how many m dashes i have in this
this long-form blog post i just put up
like what kind of crutch is this i'm
using m dashes
like they're they're going out of style
and so on and so forth so this just like
litany of
abuse just uh kind of kind of rolled off
the brain while it attacked itself and
this has been a large part of my own
resistance
the feeling that my best work is behind
me and i can't replicate it or not
replicate it because i don't want to
become an imitation of myself but
that for whatever reason like the pixie
dust
has has been lost or that i've atrophied
i've so
let the muscles atrophy that there's
just i i'm past the point of no return
have you ever contended with this uh if
you haven't like what advice
or even if you have what advice would
you give for people who are
bumping up against this because it's
been a real hindrance i recognize it's
self-imposed but it's been
a real hindrance to me actually
putting pen to paper so to speak here's
my thoughts on that tip
resistance with a capital r the force of
self-sabotage
is tremendously diabolical and
nuanced and protean and that it will
uh and subtle incredibly subtle and it
will attack us
at our weakest point and it'll usually
will attack us
in in an area where there's some truth
to what we're
what we might fear about ourselves you
know so i would say
for sure tim that thought that you have
is [ __ ]
it's resistance it's totally resistance
there's nothing wrong with you
you haven't lost any pixie dust that is
pure
resistance you it's finding a weak spot
in you you know
it's it it just knows it you know it's
like the alien knows how to get after
you right
and so um you know the form it takes for
me might be different
the you know the the weak spot it might
find in me might be different
but i think it's just finding that in
you and i think the only way
to deal with it is to just dismiss it
take my word for it it's [ __ ]
there's no grounding in it at all
just keep doing what you're doing you
know and uh
i'm sure that uh i remember i had a
friend
when i first came out into uh to los
angeles a fellow screenwriter and he got
on the phone with me one night he was in
hysteria
because he was sure that he was over the
hill and i asked him i said tom you know
how old are you he said
22. and
so this is true so resistance will find
that weak spot a [ __ ] in our armor
but uh you know don't pay any attention
to it tim dismiss it it's [ __ ]
thank you for that and i have to follow
up by asking
what purpose does resistance serve right
like
why does it exist like i try to think of
things in evolutionary terms maybe this
is just some
sort of vestigial mutation that has just
persisted but doesn't actually have
a utility but i'd love to hear your
thoughts on why it exists
i'm not sure like like seth godin thinks
it's the
the lizard brain the what is it amygdala
whatever it is
i never have quite understood but to me
and i'm going to get a little airy fairy
here a little metaphysical
i think that we if we think of our
identity
we can say that there's there's at least
two parts of it one i would call the ego
and the other i would call the self with
a capital s and the jungian sense of
self
and the ego is our rational mind
it's the part of our of us that pays
taxes
and goes down and gets a driver's
license and
becomes a lawyer or whatever whatever
right and that ego
is our eye the letter i and we obviously
have to have
an ego right we have to have that eye
that
we know how to you know stop at a
stoplight and all that sort of stuff
and then there's the other thing that
jung would call the self with a capital
s
and that self includes the deep deep
unconscious
the collective unconscious the hero's
journey the archetypes all of these
things that were
were not aware of until freud you know
finally discovered this
but that are driving us you know in a
good way
many times in a really good way and um
also according to jung the self with the
capital s
butts up against what they call the
divine
ground and i love that it's what i would
say
is where inspiration comes from it
really is
divinity it's beyond mortality it's the
muse
it's inspiration it's any time you get
into the zone
that's where you are right as an athlete
as an artist or whatever
so i'm getting back to resistance trust
me i believe you
what i think is when we as
artists or as athletes or as anything
begin to
shift our identity from our ego to our
self
when we start trusting in intuition when
we start trusting in our deep dreams
in our deep inspiration from sources
that we don't know what it is
like for me writing the novels that i
wrote that i never thought
that just came out of nowhere right that
had no made no sense
but are coming from a deeper source
anyway
when we start to identify with the self
and turn
over our nexus of control to that
the ego becomes threatened because the
ego realizes that it's going to lose
the ego strikes back and creates
resistance
and its goal is to try to
to convince us that this other world of
inspiration of intuition
of the muse or what the self is a phony
world it's
it's a [ __ ] don't pay attention to
it stay here with me
miss mr eagle i'm the ego and that's
what it is to me
and you know i just was uh i just had an
email i got into a
an email correspondent with a monk from
self-realization fellowship brother ki
vashananda are you familiar with
self-realization fellowship
i'm not anyway it's it's a wonderful
thing it's yoga
paramahansa yogananda's thing that he
started
and he was telling me about the
beyond the bhagavad-gita and the story
of arjuna and krishna
there's the the in this great battle in
the bhagavad-gita
is the ego is a character named bishma
and arjuna finally slays the ego
shooting him with 108 arrows and
he's shot so full of arrows that he's on
his back
supported by the arrows and eat and he
takes him a month to die
and even as he's dying bismarck he's
constantly spouting
his [ __ ] about how he's still in
charge he's still in charge
he's still in charge and i think that we
as artists or athletes i think
are trying to get beyond the ego or
buddhist meditators or people doing
ayahuasca
or whatever we're trying to get beyond
the ego
into whatever is next but the ego
doesn't want us to get beyond it and the
ego will hang on
and take a month to die that's what i
think resistance is
it's the ego's way of trying to hang on
to control of
us i really like that and it rings
true to me in so many
respects i mean the ego if we are not
what our ego believes us to be a lawyer
a this
we're not right someone who does x
someone who always
or never does why then what are we and
that uncertainty is very
threatening so it makes a lot of sense
that there would be
there would be a violent opposition by
the ego too
i mean i may be completely wrong but
this is my theory
yeah i it's certainly helpful
to think of it's it's a useful lens
to look at this through and
this may be very related i would love to
hear you
define or describe what it what a shadow
career
is i read a short relatively short blog
post
of yours that discussed this and i think
it's i think it's
it could be very helpful to explore i'll
give you kind of an example from
the movie business as you know in the
movie business there are
you need a lawyer there are law firms
entertainment law firms
um in fact rich roll the wonderful
podcaster and
uh athlete used to be an entertainment
lawyer he did
and entertainment lawyers directors
if you're a director an actor or writer
you have to have a lawyer because when
deals come up
you know they make the deals for you
right they get the contracts right
and i have found that
when you talk to not all entertainment
lawyers but some entertainment lawyers
secretly they want to be writers or they
want to be directors
or they ve and what they have done in
becoming lawyers
to some extent is their though their law
career is like a shadow career
it's like adjacent to what they really
want to do
they really want to direct or they
really want to write
but they for whatever reasons they were
afraid to do it
so they thought well let me i can go to
law school and that will give me uh
a trade that i an occupation a
profession i can count on
and so the law becomes kind of a shadow
career for them
or another instance of that is a lot of
times
people will work as other people's
assistants
right they'll pick up their dry cleaning
they'll do
all of that sort of stuff which can be
and that's a shadow career which can be
of course it's
also a legitimate thing it can be an
apprenticeship where you're working for
a photographer or whatever whatever
you're learning
but it also can be because a lot of
times those
people who are people's assistants
really want to do
what their boss is doing but be a
musician be a rock star but whatever it
is
but for whatever reason they're afraid
to and so they're just they have a
they pick a profession as kind of
adjacent to where they want to be but
it's not
actually doesn't have the same risk i
want to underscore this for folks
because i think it is
it is exceptionally common i see the
temptation in myself and around me in
in certain capacities so it's
it's really worth having on the radar i
think i'm going to read just a little
bit
of this blog post from 2012 which is on
your website studentpressfield.com
i think this is more from turning pro
at least that's the url so here we go
sometimes when we're terrified of
embracing our true calling we'll pursue
a shadow calling instead the shadow
career is a metaphor for our real career
its shape is similar its contours feel
tantalizingly
the same but a shadow career entails no
real risk if we fail at a shadow career
the consequences are meaningless to us
are you pursuing a shadow career are you
getting your phd
in elizabethan that's how you say that
studies because you're afraid to write
the tragedies and comedies you know you
have inside you are you living the drug
and booze half of the musician's life
without actually writing the music are
you working in a support capacity for an
innovator because you're afraid to risk
being an innovator
yourself these are really good questions
i think they're really important
questions and
the the dragon boos half example i think
is is also very important because it's
possible to
grab the romanticized
risky portions of a possible
real passion and emulate them
in a shadow career in a way that
actually has quite a lot of downside
risk with none of the upside potential
yeah true i mean i think you know not to
overstate it but sometimes
addiction is a shadow career
you know that uh you're you're acting
out the kind of
wild and crazy lifestyle rather than
actually doing the work
to do to be a musician or to be or
whatever and what do you say to people
who
would answer yes in this in the sense
that they are able to be honest with
themselves and say you're totally right
i am actually doing that
but like you said this is low risk and
the
pursuit of what i really want to do does
entail risk
and i'm afraid well there's sort of
there's kind of no way around it except
to actually
do it it's it would be if i were
advising anybody or advising myself if i
were in that condition i would
i would say you know get get into some
kind of therapy
get into something that will help you
elevate your consciousness about this
let you
explore it introspection and at some
point it will become
pretty clear what your real dream is
you know maybe uh if you're a
photographer's assistant
you really say oh i want to be a
cinematographer i'd love to be
vilmos zigman you know i want to shoot
scorsese's next movie whatever
that's i'd love to do that then it's
sort of a matter of kind of
i hate to talk about the ego but getting
back into rationality and saying okay
how do i pursue that should i go to
school
should i apprentice myself on a track
that will actually take me there
or should i uh you know uh you know
whatever
figure out what the actual track is that
will get you to that dream
and then the other thing i'd say is
talking to myself again is
be very aware of your own tendency to
self-sabotage
of resistance and watch out for any of
those
mental self conversations
that will try to talk you out of doing
it you know
build up your professional habits and
and just go for it
you know just go for it i'll add one
thing to that which has been very
helpful to me
so i'm saying this to myself also
because it's probably time for me to do
this again with respect to
to writing and that is take a look
at an exercise you can find it online
called fear setting
that i've written quite a bit about and
i also did a ted talk related to the
subject
because it's saved my life in some ways
and it's
really just a re-phrasing and presenting
of an exercise from
the stoics called primitio malorum so
meditating on the worst case
this is just a practice of actually
putting to paper
what the worst things are that could
happen how you might mitigate against
them
how you could minimize the damage or
reverse the damage
and as seneca the younger
has said of course not in english and
i'm paraphrasing here but we see
we suffer more in imagination than in
reality
and uh it's easy to believe
or to overestimate the threats
that exist from action while
underestimating the risks of inaction
when they're trapped in your head but
when you put them on paper it actually
loses
oftentimes a lot of its force so i would
just recommend people take uh take a
look at
fear setting with a hyphen in the middle
let's talk about a man at arms you have
your creative how-to books the war of
art turning pro do the work and so on
then you have your historical fiction
which is just outstanding gates of fire
tides of war
the afghan campaign and now a man at
arms
why did you write this new book how did
it come to be what was the genesis story
before we've gone away let me talk go
come back and talk about fear setting i
want to say something after that when
we're done
i have there's only been like one
recurring character in
my in my historical fiction and he is
this sort of
uh gunslinger of the ancient world
telamon of arcadia
a one-man killing machine of the ancient
world and he's been in three books of
mine
and as a minor character but i've always
been fascinated by this guy and in fact
a lot of readers have been fascinated by
him too
and i've always wanted to write a book
only about him
and this is another kind of weird thing
to him about the creative process a lot
of times
i will block out a story and i know
exactly what each character represents
and who they are and
what they're going to do but this one
character telemon the one-man killing
machine of the ancient world
came on the page to me fully formed
i didn't plan him i had no idea where he
came from
and he not only was he fully formed but
he had a deep
philosophy and a very dark philosophy a
real warrior
samurai philosophy and so i wanted to
write this book about him because
only about him because i wanted to
follow his journey
it's really he was really sort of in the
other stories at the end of his hero's
journey
and i was wondering where was he going
to go from there
and for like 13 years i tried to come up
with a story that would work
and i just did outline after outline i
never could find it
and finally i just had a flash about
adding to his world a young vulnerable
girl a nine-year-old girl a mute
girl and somehow that sort of cracked
the story for me
and so this book came very fast
it's set in first century a.d right
after the crucifixion
in jerusalem and in the sinai desert and
i just really i just wanted this guy
character of telamon
is sort of an alter ego for me i know on
some crazy
unconscious level i'm bound to this
character in some way
and his story is my story in some way oh
i don't know what it is
and so i i wanted you know writing as
you know
particularly fiction is like a dream
in that in that you you enter another
dimension of
reality when you're sitting down to
write and you don't know what's going to
come
a lot of times the work takes on a life
of its own
and it'll pull you along so that was
this book for me
i wanted to see where telamon would go
and what his arc would be
and i know i'm gonna have to write
another one because i haven't got to the
end of it yet
but that's where that was the genesis of
a man at arms
and when you write a book like this
since i have no experience with fiction
although i'm endlessly fascinated by it
i think i'm afraid of it honestly
because i read good fiction and i think
to myself because it's a good reason to
be afraid good lord i can just cannot
i just don't know how humans do this do
you write a book like this
simply because you are a
a writer and fiction is a way of
exploring
this alternate reality is it because you
hope it to impart
certain messages or lessons that people
will
learn from what are the reasons behind
an undertaking i'm absolutely a believer
as you know
of the in the muse you know i believe in
another dimension of reality i believe
that there is
that books or songs or
businesses exist in the in the realm of
potential
before they exist in the real world and
i believe that as a
you know as a writer i i am a servant of
the muse and i believe this book a man
at arms
existed it existed in that other
dimension
and i was called on to bring it forth
in this in this dimension so i'm really
not i really don't have a message
i really don't have uh i do want to
explore
certain aspects of the character but
mainly this story
just kind of sees me and i felt like
i've got to tell this story i've got to
get it
i've got to make it work in a hero's
journey terms and i've got to tell it
in the right way and solve all those
problems but mainly i just
i just wanted to tell this story like a
like a singer would want to sing a
certain song
or a dancer would want to dance a
certain dance so that that was the
reason it's just the story just seized
me
and came very fast and very easy
what would you say if you have an answer
for this distinguishes
the books that come fascinating easy
from
those that are more difficult those that
are maybe a
just a hard slog it seems the hard ones
don't work
and the easy ones do you know it's
almost like if it's hard maybe it's a
reason why it's hard right why are you
pushing the boulder uphill
right which is not to say even the easy
ones are
hard in the sense that um there are a
lot of technical problems to solve
like i just was doing a i just did a
video on instagram i was talking about
the original manuscript of gates of fire
was 802 pages long and i
and the book was finally 384 so i had to
cut
basically cut it in half so that was
like a technical problem that was hard
but the book itself was easy right the
book you know came with a lot of energy
just like i mean at arms just kind of
came you know in fact i don't even have
really a memory
of writing it you know i know i wrote it
last year
but it just came in a real rush
i would love to experience more of that
in my writing
it sounds like i just have to get on the
playing field
a bit more often you know sight unseen
tim we don't know each other it's the
first time we've really talked for a
long time
and if you'll forgive me for being your
psychotherapist here for a second
yes please i think maybe you should
think about writing fiction at some
point
i i agree with you i agree with you i do
i do i think i am
psyching myself out and i think it would
be so freeing for me to do it because my
non-fiction books are so carefully
meticulously architected there are no
surprises i mean they're they're
everything is intended to be as clear
which is fine and prescriptive and
represent such a logical sequence and
building right i know what you mean
but for the writer for me uh there
there's very little element of surprise
that
harnessing of the muse is minimal in a
sense right it exists
with turns of phrase and certain
thoughts about
composition but i appreciate you saying
that and
and i agree i would like to try some
fiction and
you know just write it maybe for a
handful of friends although let me make
one comment
actually coming way back to something
you said at the very early
beginnings of this conversation when you
said you wrote a novel and even your
friends wouldn't read it
i wanted to just say that
if you write for those people out there
who haven't written much
don't be overly offended or demoralized
if your friends don't read it because
my friends and especially my family i'm
not going to
name out names are the last people who
will ever read my stuff
including now and i think it's just kind
of like
sometimes absolutely true i couldn't
agree more tim
and there's there's a reason for that
too they
they are the last people who i couldn't
get my mother to read
anything you know it's because they are
the people who are close to you since
when you write something or you take a
chance they sense
you changing you're becoming a different
person
and their their fears they're going to
lose you
and so they want to make you stay the
way you are and
and that's it's in a crazy way it's love
it's out of love
but it's a dark side of love let me say
a couple of things to you tim for
whatever this is worth forgive me for
being please um presumptuous
but if you do decide to write fiction
here's what i would suggest first of all
don't start small don't say oh well let
me write a short story
because that's kind of a [ __ ] way of
doing it do
seriously and the muse doesn't like that
she wants you to go big
you know so go for something big i would
suggest
and also the way you'll know the idea
is that it will be terrifying to you
prospect of
of of exposing yourself to do this
and that's the one you should do i love
that
and i encourage you to do that
so don't don't piss off the muse with
small ambitions
really or maybe not piss off don't
insult the muse i mean a
four-hour work week was a big idea a
huge idea you know
and an idea that could have you could
have fallen completely on your face
you know people could have just laughed
you out of
but you did it you know and it worked so
i would say you know to the same concept
only with fiction
thank you i i'm gonna take that to heart
let me get back for one second to fear
setting there's just one thing i wanted
to say
yes please um to reinforce what you were
saying
a few years ago i wrote a book called
the lion's gate which was about
the 1967 arab-israeli war
the six-day war and i went over to
israel and i interviewed a bunch of
fighter pilots
and i had never really talked to fighter
pilots before
and the thing that was that isn't that
they have in common
the mindset of a fighter pilot is
exactly what you were saying like
when before they would go up on a
mission they would sit down and
for hours in solitude run
the mission in their mind thinking of
every possible thing that could go wrong
you know what if i get a flame out over
the sinai desert you know what if my
guns don't fire
what if i'm attacked from out of the sun
whatever
and they would sort of in their mind
play out all of these
worst case scenarios and when they had
played them out and they knew what they
were going to do then they were ready to
go
and i thought that is a great way to
think about things
you know because the last thing you
always want to have
to be able to have to save something is
oh i never saw it coming
right so i i hardly agree with that
that idea of fear setting that whole
stoic concept i think it's a great thing
let's use that as a jumping off point
to something i know very little about
but i've seen it come up
in in some discussions and that is the
concept of
i'm not going to get the pronunciation
here correct but
yet sir
what is yet to hara you know i wish i
had my rabbi rabbi mordecai
finley here to explain it to us but he
uh
apparently it's a it's a phrase from
genesis
and it's translated by rabbi finley as a
turning toward evil
and he has said to me that this is a
concept in kabbalistic thought and
jewish mysticism
and it's the equivalent of my concept of
resistance with a capital r
it's that force that exists in the world
to stop us
from going to a lower level to a higher
level like in
to realizing our calling to coming into
our own it's that negative force
and in jewish mysticism there's a
concept uh
that life happens on more than one
dimension
and that we live on the material
dimension and above us
is a higher dimension that's called the
neshama and that is the soul
and the the what they talk about the
soul
is that above every blade of grass
is an angel saying grow
grow the soul or what i would say would
be the unconscious of the muse
is actively engaged in our life
and trying to help us and we are trying
to reach
up to the soul at the same time the soul
is trying to reach down to us
and help us and in between the two
is this force called the yetzer this
negative force of self-sabotage
and when rabbi finley told me that that
that was
something that existed in jewish thought
for years and years i thought ah i'm not
crazy
other people have thought about the same
thing and
so actually in genesis
as i understand this right i may be
getting it wrong but
the is the story where god decides to
destroy the human race
and he he regrets and repents that he
made us
and he looks down he sees what and he
sees everywhere
a turning toward evil meaning this is
the yetzer hara
and this is when god decides to send a
flood you know to wipe us out and
and noah survived right so it's
in in this kind of spiritual sense it's
almost a flaw
in the universe that um when god created
us at least according to kabbalistic
thought
he made a mistake he screwed up a buggy
and bugging the software
yeah a bug in the software and if you
certainly if you look at the human race
there is a turning toward evil
everywhere right there's something wrong
with us
and um i would say it's a lack of
connection to the soul
what we were talking about about the
self and the ego of resistance and
everything
so in any event that's what that's what
the yetzer hurrah is
as i understand it i may be wrong but as
i understand it in uh
kabbalistic jewish mysticism so i would
love to ask just a few more questions
and the first few are going to be
related to my homework assignment or
recommendation
of writing fiction so you said go big
uh and uh in my mind i'm thinking that
could mean a novel could mean
a screenplay so i'd like you to
elaborate on what that means but also
i know that i have a tendency
to read and prepare perhaps excessively
often as a form of procrastination right
i can read
ten books uh before i ever set pen to
paper
since i have no exposure or experience
with fiction writing
are there any books i should read or
things i should consider
before i begin or literally should i
just say to myself i'm going to write a
novel i don't even know how novels are
structured
but i'm gonna start with page one
today so there's the question of what is
big what does that actually mean
to you and then how much preparation if
any
or education is the right amount before
beginning
i think when i say go big i think
that the muse likes it you know fortune
favors the bold
and i think when we when we try for
something
big we're taking the initiative
and we're kind of um invoking a tailwind
behind us
whereas if we're kind of timid and we
say oh well just let me do this small
little thing that i'm going to do
i don't think the muse likes that and i
know like in advertising when i was
working in advertising
i used to come up with the tiniest ideas
it was really pathetic you know when i
bring them in with the boss
and they would like just throw me out
you know this is an idea the size of a
postage stamp you know get the [ __ ] out
of here you know
come back with something big and it was
really hard for me to do
you know because i was afraid of it so i
do think going big
help invokes the muse in a good way and
sort of as a parallel to that tim i
would say even though
eventually you are going to have to
learn what the story principles are
i would say just plunge in um and
follow just do something that you love i
mean i have
it's too bad we're not on video here
because i have behind me
a book by a friend of mine mike
mcclelland called the san c
and it's like 780 pages long or
something
and mike is a lawyer he's a functioning
lawyer he's got a wife and kids
and over like a 13-year period he would
get up at the crack of dawn
and you know go out to his garage where
he had an office
and he would put in he would write 500
words a day
but this this book the cnc is a huge
book it's like a tolkien type of book
and uh you know with all kinds of crazy
characters from everywhere
and i really applaud that he did it that
way and
now he's on to the second book in the
trilogy there's gonna be a third one
so for him going big really worked and i
and it has gone it has worked for me too
that doesn't mean it necessarily has to
be 800 pages long
but just a big idea an idea it's kind of
a scary idea
that you you say to yourself when i show
this to people
they're going to look at me and go what
happened to you tim are you okay you
know
that's where uh what i mean by big and
should i just assume this is never going
to be read by anyone is that
a helpful assumption to make a couple of
follow-up questions
do it only for yourself okay but only
for yourself and is the because when i
hear
stories of someone working on things say
in the mornings like the kite runner
right but i mean the same because
similar
story i think the author was working in
medicine at the time and would wake up
super early and
worked for a long period of time on this
book
when i think of my first foray
into fiction if i think it's going to be
a homework assignment like a daily
homework assignment for years
there is a very large part of me that
just does not want to do it unless
the purpose behind it is therapy or
this is going to be cultivating your
connection
with this other dimension you've
described and that's the purpose of
doing this
do you have any thoughts on those points
or concerns i mean it may be
tim that writing fiction is your calling
i don't know it could very well be you
could say that
non-fiction books and and podcasts and
stuff like that
might be if you'll forgive me might be a
shadow career for you
i don't know yeah yeah so in that case
the exercise of writing fiction would be
uh like a lifelong calling you know a
practice from now till the end
and and i would think that it i think
it's a good idea to hope
that it will be successful that it'll
find a market that people will love it
you know
but at the same time i think it's very
important that i'm talking to myself too
to turn off the self-censor and not
start to think oh [ __ ] are people going
to like this or
is this have i gone too far in this
scene you know in other words trying to
second-guess the audience
because an audience if it's out there
it'll find it you know it'll find the
work
um and if it isn't it won't but i would
say just write to please yourself
and always take the brave choice you
know should i write this scene this way
it's kind of a chicken way
or should i go really go for it and
write it the big way
and i would say always take the brave
choice and
monitor yourself as you go because what
should happen
is once you're into this you should
really start to feel good
you should really feel a tailwind and
really feel like oh
[ __ ] my feet are on the ground you know
this is you know
i may be a beginner and maybe i don't
know what i'm doing but i'm on the right
path
and if it doesn't feel like that then
maybe it's not the right idea
well i uh it's okay with you i may i may
reach out to you
as my yeah please do in fact we do
absolutely
as my uh my stabilizing wing
uh at at some point and
i i'm serious jim please do thank you
i really appreciate that stephen this
has been so much fun i
would love to do another round at some
point have another conversation like
this
there's put me down in the books
whenever there's no shortage
of of topics to cover and
maybe after i've actually given this a
shot i think that should be
the stakes that should be the
accountabilities i can't have you on
again
until i have actually spent some time on
this scary thing
called fiction and just a few
last questions and this one doesn't
always work out but i like to ask it
and it's not an easy question
necessarily but if you had a billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a message
or a quote or a question or an image out
to billions of people
assuming they would all understand it
what might you put on that billboard
ah and you know actually this was a
question in tribe of mentors that i
actually don't even answer to
it was but what i said in that in tribe
of mentors was
uh i would not put up any billboard at
all and i would tear them all down
but to answer your question a little
more seriously
you know because you're sort of saying
well what's what would be kind of a if
you had to say
one thing to somebody to help them
exactly
i would say life is
is long this is what a friend of mine
phil slot once said to me he said they
always tell you
life is short but actually life is long
and
if we find ourselves making mistakes or
we haven't yet found our real calling
don't drive yourself crazy with that you
know
there's plenty of time everybody thinks
they've got
oh if i don't do it in the next six
months i'm gonna kill myself you know
and i thought that too forever but look
at me it took me forever
to break through into anything and i
still feel that i've got
a whole other lifetime ahead of me and
you know you tim you've got like three
lifetimes ahead of me so
be patient with yourself i would say to
people be kind to yourself
you're on a journey whether you realize
it or not we all are
there's no way not to be and things will
reveal themselves
as they go but don't beat yourself up
too much
stephen uh this has been so much fun i
really appreciate you taking the time
and people can find you at steven
pressfield again with a v
stevenpressfield.com twitter at s press
field instagram steven underscore
press field we'll link to all of your
books including the newest
and one that i'm quite excited about a
man at arms an epic saga about a
reluctant hero the roman empire and the
rise of a new
faith uh checking all the boxes for me
and are there any other comments you'd
like to make
any requests of my audience any
uh parting questions or anything at all
that you'd like to add before we bring
this
this conversation no i think that
billboard that's
that's my billboard yeah that would be
that would be the final thing other than
to say you know thanks for having me tim
it's great talking to you getting to
know you a little bit
and i hope i didn't overstep my bounds
and uh
you know giving unsolicited advice but
uh
um i hope i hope what i said helps a
little bit
and uh you know we'll we'll talk again i
i think i think you know if this writing
thing doesn't work out for you maybe
that's your shadow career
for becoming a psychoanalyst maybe that
is your real calling
all right and i have found this very
helpful personally
and i'm sure it will help many other
people out there
so thank you again stephen and to
everyone listening
once again you can find links to
everything that we mentioned
at tim.log forward slash podcast
and until next time thank you for tuning
in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow
dug up in the uh the world of the
esoteric
as i do it could include favorite
articles
that i've read and that i've shared with
my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four-hour
workweek.com that's 4hourworkweek.com
all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find
a more nutrient-dense and comprehensive
formula on the market it has multi
vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us
are deficient in vitamin d i found that
true for myself
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine is a
great option for additional immune
support to support your immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
tonal t-o-n-a-l i'm super excited about
this one
and i was skeptical of it in the
beginning tonal
quote tonal is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to total by three different
friends
all of them are tech savvy one of them
is a former competitive skier
who's doubled his strength in a number
of moments using tonal even though
he has a long athletic background
and i'll paint a picture for you by
eliminating traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells total can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights
up and down with the touch of a button
in one pound increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting a tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym
such as the chop and lift exercises from
four-hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after one workout
on total focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects of
the engineering and smart features check
your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest